من المسافه صفر وحيث يقيم جنود الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي حاجزا غير دائم عند المدخل
الغربي لبلده سلواد شرقيه رام الله اطلق
جنود الاحتلال رصاصه على الشهيد احمد
كحلان البالغ من العمر 45 عاما واصابته في
عنقه تنوعت روايات الجيش الاسرائيلي من
محاوله طعن الى خطف سلاح لكن شهود عيان
قدموا روايه مختلفه
في الناس
الرايقه فصار زمره فبلشوا في قنابل الصوت
في السيارات
في سياره الشهيد فالشهيد يعني استفز شويه
فصي عليهم هجم على السياره على الشهيد
ونزل لهم السياره قدامي وادموه قدام بارد
مشهد تشييع الشهيد كحله الذي كان يعيد
اربعه من الابناء من رام الله الى مسقط
راسه في بلده رامون شرقي المدينه
طالب في الانتقام وردت بالصمت الدولي تجاه
ما ترتكبه اسرائيل في حق الفلسطيني
وقد اعادت حادثه استشهاد الكحله الى
الاذهان جرائم اعدام الميدانيه الاخرى
تكررت في انحاء المتفرقه منظفه الغربيه
والقدس المحتله ومن ضمنها اغتيال عمار
مفلح الذي اعدمه جندي اسرائيلي على شارع
حوار الرئيسي جنوب نابلس في الثاني من
ديسمبر الماضي
وتفتح هذه الجرائم حسب الفلسطينيين الباب
امامهم لملاحظه اسرائيل قضائيا في المحاكم
الدوليه المختصه نحن نتبعها بشكل يومي
ومتتابع مع مكتب المدعي العام للجنائيه
الدوليه ونرفع له تقارير دوريه حول هذا
التصعيد في جرائم الاعدامات الميداليه
ونطالب الجنائيه الدوليه بسرعه الانتهاء
من تحقيق من تحقيقاتها وصولا لمساءله
ومحاسبه ومحاكمه مجرمي الحرب الاسرائيليين
استشهاده كحله واعدامه من مسافه السفر يدل
في راي الفلسطينيين على حاله الباك ل
الاحتلال ويرونه ترجمه لسياسه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الجديده
الماضيه في استفسار اطلاق الرصاص على
الفلسطينيه
سمير ابو شمالي الجزيره رام الله فلسطين